[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the common car tester Michelle
Assenmacher isn't Britain to test minis
new countrymen she's going to try it out
off-road after off-road cycles the
second generation of this subcompact
crossover was introduced in the fall of
2016 it's available with the full range
of engines and the new all-wheel drive
system all for an electro-hydraulic
differential that redirects power to the
back wheels when the front wheels lose
traction in extreme conditions the
all-wheel powertrain is connected to the
dynamic Stability control which tells it
the optimum distribution of power
between the front and rear axles that
helps keep the new mini on track even in
the slipperiest conditions
[Music]
so as OD Michelle's taking the MINI
Countryman across a highly demanding
stretch with deep mud holes and came out
in one piece now she'll take a clean car
and test it on the regular roads I'm
solving an auto in the minis home people
drive on the left another challenge for
Michelle she keeps a little reminder in
plain sight on the rearview mirror
[Music]
this version puts out 141 kilowatts of
power and accelerates to 100 km/h and
just seven point three seconds many
rates average fuel consumption at 7.1
litres per 100 kilometers prices start
at thirty one thousand nine hundred
euros in Germany the new countryman
offers a choice of four inches to
gasoline powered and two Diesel's with a
plug-in hybrid coming in June 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
so it shall boast that she's taken down
the keep left reminder because thanks to
the many Countryman's good all-round
visibility she feels quite at home in
England's traffic avoid dear after
functions I had to finish the defendant
the first generation MINI Countryman
sold nearly five hundred fifty thousand
units a solid base for the second to
build on it offers a number of new
features besides the new MINI Countryman
is no longer so many it's added 20
centimeters in length and 3 and width
extending its wheelbase by seven and a
half centimeters and making for a
roomier interior
[Music]
the cockpit has a new touch display
equipped with the MINI Connected
infotainment system
the front seats can be adjusted
electrically the rear seats easily and
quickly transform into a lounge for two
people
the trunk holds 450 litres expanding to
thirteen hundred and ninety with the
rear seats folded down the in Hong
Michelle says the mini countrymen's
interior is playful and finds that she
can adjust and set things to her heart's
content over the new touch display she
especially likes the switches on the
center console saying they feel great
and seem well made the only thing she
doesn't like is the gas gauge it seems a
bit yesterday say I'd bucket the more
spacious countryman can now serve as a
family first car it handles well both
off road and on city streets and it has
a little something extra vests on
firearms and zoo anomalies finally
Michelle points out that if you want to
take in the air a bit after a long
working day you can roll out the many
Countryman's picnic bench picnic bench
to sit comfortably in back ed commune
with nature hampton inn Zetts nest oh my
Cantina toga neeson
[Music]
Mitsubishi has given the Lancer a
makeover among the features are a front
end facelift new rims and an updated
interior it's available in sedan or
sportback models we tested the sport
back the new front has a wide front
bumper painted in the same color of the
car and a horizontal radiator grille
with chrome
[Music]
what's more there are new headlights
with LED daytime running lights on the
sides this feature however is standard
only in the plus and top equipment
packages a look at the lancer sportback
from the side reveals a flaw that's
remained in the revamped model something
about you busy car test a manuel shaver
says the car still has blind spots just
like before its face lift the Lancer had
very wide c-pillars a small rear window
and the back seat headrests are
difficult to lower this makes it
difficult for the driver to see what's
behind the car the fundation try next
time thank goodness a reverse assist
camera is available as an option come on
yet if you want this driving aid you've
got to choose the plus package or higher
mitsubishi a thirsty mono says
Mitsubishi has taken some of the
criticism of its customers too hard
because whereas the previous model at
only 270 cubic liters of trunk space a
new Lancer can fit far more cargo with
400 de l'homme the interior still has
clean lines says he ma noel with only a
few climate control knobs the touch
screen does the rest but it's a shame
even the more expensive models still
don't come with a sat-nav always getting
off place via the asada enzymes it's
come for Emmanuel says the car is
comfortable but he finds that the sides
of the seats are far too soft Jesus I
can't I bet he's in all the advice
that's how so when the car is cornering
you're sort of thrown off balance dafli
craft invited guba unnecessary advice is
making the sides of the sheets firmer or
redesigning the sheeting it's an
Instagram been sniffing ah skeet
the engines are known quantities they
both run on gasoline and produce 86 and
103 kilowatts of power respectively
we're testing the smaller 1.6 litre
model it can take the lancer sportback
from zero to one hundred and ten point
seven seconds with a maximum speed of
191 km/h the manufacturer says it uses
five point five liters of fuel to travel
100 kilometers
[Music]
as gift for dinner man whoa says the
lancer sportback comes with either a 1.8
liter gasoline engine with a CVT
automatic or what we're driving a 1.6
litre five-speed manual he says the
five-speed is outdated most cars in this
range already have six speed
transmissions it remains to be seen
whether the facelifted Lancer will be
carried on for another generation
because Mitsubishi is already planning a
midsize sedan for its renault-nissan
alliance industry analysts say this
model could follow the Lancer perhaps
under a new name as well
[Music]
howdy presents the QA concept car a
plug-in hybrid a 3-litre turbocharge
fuel stratified injection engine teams
up with an electric motor to generate
330 kilowatts and 700 newton meters of
torque the q8 is based on the new q7 s
platform Audi says the q8 burns 2.3
liters per 100 kilometers the concept
car is the basis for a model slated to
roll off the assembly lines and 2018
Porsche presents its Panamera for a
hybrid in the executive version with a
wheelbase widened by 15 centimetres this
chauffeur sedan with hybrid
gasoline-electric power train gets 340
kilowatts and accelerates like a 911
turbo it has 700 newton meters of torque
from the start thanks to a boost
function it reaches 100 kilometers an
hour in just 4.6 seconds
[Music]
ever since Alexis first rolled out the
is it's been one of the Toyota luxury
divisions premiere models more than a
million in three generations have been
sold globally in 17 years this Lexus was
developed especially for the European
market and now it's been given a
makeover if and along your testing eNOS
Paisley says the ISS facelift only
changed a few small details a touch or
two on the exterior a new concept for
the switches and a new safety package
also new is the suspension it gives the
driver more direct contact with the road
and makes driving a bit more fun if half
why this Diagon
we tested the hybrid model B 300h it
currently accounts for a good ninety
percent of all is sales whether hybrid
or turbo gasoline variants the facelift
hasn't affected the powertrain but
enhanced aerodynamics have reduced
average fuel consumption by a marginal
tenth of a leader 400 kilometers
[Music]
the axles sharks and chassis have been
retuned for a stiffer suspension this is
the principal difference to its
predecessor this together with new
software for the variable gear ratio
steering adds up to more responsive
steering the f-sport variant we tested
also features adaptive suspension
[Music]
the fondue eNOS recalls that the
suspension and the road feedback had
always been subject to criticism so was
a good decision for the engineers to
start there now she's glad to be testing
the sports variant with the sport
suspension and she can't find anything
about the road feedback or the steering
to complain about it responds to her
very directly and leaves her with a
positive impression on the outside only
a few details have been changed the
spindle shaped grills waistline has
shifted upwards and the visual focal
point moved downwards the air intakes
and running lights are new and a little
removed from the headlights
[Music]
the head and tail light technology is
entirely in LEDs now
the Panda so the Venus explains that the
cars Japanese soul is expressed in tiny
details and described by the term Takumi
which means high craftsmanship she
points out the leather dashboard over
the instrument cluster with decorative
stitching and the wooden applications
worked with a special kind of laser
technology lexus is also has a new 10.3
inch display and the adaptive suspension
brought with it an additional mode
allowing the driver to set the cars
character according to personal
preferences
hey this recognizes the little joystick
from the last version of the vehicle but
the to enter buttons left and right are
new they send off whatever the operator
enters the idea is to make it more
intuitive and easier to operate eNOS has
a positive overall impression of the
facelift on every point she thought the
design of the front had always been
fairly offbeat and now it's even more so
the concept for the controls has
simplified them a noticeable improvement
and the suspension makes driving more
fun so all in all she'd call it a
success listen a woman alone over in
Germany the new lexus is 300h starts at
about thirty eight thousand five hundred
euros
[Music]
deccan quad-core Chester Sasha can op
reminds us the competition in the luxury
class is very tough even major
manufacturers like Audi and BMW have a
hard time up against the leader of the
fact the Mercedes s-class and so it's
hardly surprising when some of them
tinker with their positioning for
example Maserati with knee quattroporte
or Porsche with the Panamera and now
that's what Jaguar is doing with the XJ
difficult while older Jaguars maintain
the British tradition of understatement
the new XJ is much sporty-er than its
predecessors Jaguar describes this model
as its most daring interpretation to
date the XJ came out with a facelift in
2016 this version offers LED headlights
and rear lights the power steering is
now electromechanical
[Music]
inside this big cat simply purrs with
luxury quilted leather seats are
reminiscent of Baroque design the
meridian sound system with up to 1300
wats pampers passengers in the portfolio
variant a 12 point 3 inch HD display
serves as instrument panel the 8 inch
display in the middle console can
operate by touch as with modern
smartphones it recognizes the swipe
the trunk has five hundred twenty liters
of storage space benin desk sasha says
that the right hand back seat may be the
most comfortable spot in the mercedes
s-class but in the Jaguar XJ the
driver's seat is best leg room in the
back seat is adequate but the Headroom
isn't so great still there is plenty of
comfort and luxury with seat heating
that can also cook and for zone air
conditioning as well it's on kima
automatic
[Music]
I invite telescope another comfort
feature is the nonlinear steering the
wheels not only turned more the more you
turn the steering wheel the rate at
which they turn increases that's
especially convenient when you want to
park or shunt this feature may not
please everyone but Sasha likes it our
test car with the portfolio package
costs just under ninety three thousand
euros in Germany Jaguar says combined
fuel consumption is 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers two engines are available
with the portfolio package this diesel
and a three liter gasoline engine
be fun and I'm Sasha is testing the
3-litre diesel it puts out 221 kilowatts
or 300 horsepower and 700 newton meters
of torque that's quite a bit Sasha likes
that the tried and true ZF 8-speed
automatic transmission transmits power
to the rear axle almost silently on the
hint ox the vitagua at the Jaguar XJ
glides over the blacktop with effortless
elegance
[Music]
yes nothing sasha says top-notch
acoustic insulation makes the cars
comfort perfect even the sound of the
horn hardly reaches the interior an app
enables the owner to carry out many
functions via smartphone for example he
receives an immediate warning if the car
is broken into or stolen the car can
also be located with a nap plus you can
preheat the interior or check your fuel
gauge with a smartphone all-wheel drive
is available only in combination with
the gasoline engine the diesel engine
comes only with rear-wheel drive a
5-liter v8 kompressor comes in the XJR
model which costs about fifty thousand
euros more than the XJ version we're
testing it produces 405 kilowatts
[Music]
the one disease Russia regrets that his
luxurious drive must come to an end when
parking remember that the Jaguar XJ is a
large car and visibility around it isn't
as good as might be desired but that's
why it comes with a 360 degree panoramic
camera if you rely on the rearview
mirror remember that the rear window is
extremely sloped which means you can't
really see the rear end of the car from
inside the sasha says he had a lot of
fun driving the Jaguar XJ with a 3-litre
diesel engine and that the driver's seat
is definitely the best place in this
sedan limousine the legendary alfa romeo
logo back in nineteen seventy one in
greece the radiator grille of a
front-wheel-drive compact for the first
time the alfasud the italian automaker
hoped the car would help but attract new
customers and they wanted to stimulate
the local economy to as our classy car
expert christophe our explains when
medida mama delta austrian car designer
una pushka was given the mammoth task of
creating the car he'd previously worked
under ferdinand porsche on the VW Beetle
and had helped develop the Giulietta for
alfa romeo in the early 1950s risca made
plans not only for the car but also for
a new factory in Palm Liano darko near
Naples and he quickly dubbed the car the
Alpha zoot the Alpha of the south
Buddha husker was well connected and
assembled a team of four Murphy of
Engineers starting from scratch they
designed a compact car that was very
progressive for its time it boasted
plenty of space and aerodynamic shape
and sporty performance there was just
one problem bidhan cuts at that size
rust Christo says it quickly ruined the
alphas UN's reputation by the time the
first vehicle inspections rolled around
some parts had completely rusted through
and a few alphas oods were completely
unsalvageable after just four years
that's because staff at the Alpha plants
but almost as much time on strike as
they did working so body shells
sometimes spent weeks sitting around in
the salty sea air and rust said in even
before they were painted the company's
quick fix of filling the vehicles hollow
cavities with synthetic foam just made
things worse it soaked up water like a
sponge producing more rust that was a
shame because otherwise the alfasud is a
well-engineered car
let's guests I've Christophe explains
that it was the first alfa romeo to use
for a wheel drive while safer than
traditional rear-wheel drive it can make
for dull driving but not in the alfasud
it's fun and great on curves thanks to
Rudolf Houska and his great suspension
with macpherson struts at the front and
a pressed steel rear axle unusual for a
front-wheel drive model it tends to
oversteer due to the negative camber at
the front normally only seen in race
cars stores except for that later so
what's good son Stevie's mother hanbok
except for a hatchback the office suit
had all the ingredients which would
three years later make the Volkswagen
Golf such a success the sky go ad free
stuff says the officers design was
decades ahead of its time the short
overhangs allow for a long wheelbase and
combined with the steep fastback makes
for heaps of room inside and that was
head designer Udo first cos intention he
was also two meters tall and wanted to
build an Italian car that could seat for
central Europeans comfortably the body
was styled by none other than giorgetto
giugiaro designer of the first VW golf
this st la liga 'the the alfasud shape
is very aerodynamic a compact boxer
engine allows for a flat hood and a low
center of gravity sloping rear also
optimizes airflow and improves handling
[Music]
inside the car exudes a sporty kind of
purism plastic and rubber are used to
create a clearly arranged an ergonomic
cockpit the lack of creature comforts
allowed alfa romeo to sell the car for
an unbeatable price equivalent to around
4,000 euros Danya christophe is also
impressed by the compact boxer engine
with 1.2 or later up to 1.5 liters of
cubic capacity from the start they left
enough room to increase capacity the
first alfasud from 1971 eeks 63
horsepower out of one point two liters
of cubic capacity the car Christoph is
driving is a 1.3 liter engine with an
output of 68 horsepower he says in 1972
German trade magazine auto motor and
sport praised the cars incredibly quiet
engine which produced little vibration
even at high revs yet the 1.3 liter
boxer engine is very agile and you could
even rev it up to 7,000 rpm for short
periods it's a real alfin and a dolly
so the little alpha was able to live up
to the great expectations buyers had of
an Alfa Romeo soon the car maker
expanded the alfasud range to include
the John Dean at the station wagon and
the Sprint sports coupe a although over
1 million of these cars were produced
few have survived if nothing kagaz
Christa finds it tragic that people
today only associate the office suit
with rust because this car was arguably
the most progressive of its time created
in the 1960s it was still
state-of-the-art in the 90s its design
anticipated the shapes of many compact
sedans build years later so rust or not
Christophe says the alfasud was a stroke
of genius and a milestone in automotive
history at the time competitors accused
Alfa Romeo selling the car at dumping
prices the office sued Spartan interior
coupled with its progressive technology
added up to great driving pleasure at an
affordable price
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]